gonna go over the Muay Thai clinch which
I see a lot of guys do in MMA and they
can cause a lot of damage so if we're
here and you're in reaching distance
yeah I'm just gonna grab you here B
hands behind the head here yeah you feel
this yeah
well for me there are but I know you
mean yeah well maybe for the kid there's
a lot of options in general there's not
yeah I can go knee here knee elbow elbow
All I'm gonna do is keep you I'm not I'm
not gonna stay stationary I'm moving
around the whole time you see how I just
stroll you around it's like a little
baby chicken until I can see it until I
don't know how to count them all you do
here is take your hands okay okay you
gotta just don't panic now just keep
popping okay okay go ahead and pop it me
oh